WITH ME NOW.
HE SPENT MONTHS LOOKING INTO
ALEX JONES IN HIS SPECIAL REPORT
CALLED "MEGAPHONE FOR
CONSPIRACY" IS COMING UP IN JUST
A FEW MINUTES.
DREW, YOU TALKED TO PEOPLE WHO
KNOW THIS MAN, WHO WORK FOR HIM
HAND MOST SHOCKINGLY REALLY
BELIEVE HUM.
>> Reporter: AND WHAT IS SO
SURPRISING TO MOST OF US WHO
HAVE BEEN WATCHING FROM AFAR
THIS, ALEX JONES WHO REALLY HAS
BEEN DISREGARDED AS THIS
INTERNET CLOWN, IS HOW
INTRICATELY HE IS INVOLVED IN
THE FINANCING, PLANNING AND THE
POSSIBILITY THE INSURRECTION
TOOK PLACE THAT TOOK PLACE ON
JANUARY 6th.
>> USA!
USA!
>> AS FEDERAL AGENTS ZEROED IN
ON JANUARY 6th, ALEX JONES'
INFLUENCE WAS ON DISPLAY.
>> IF YOU'VE GOT TO FIGHT YOU
BETTER BELIEVE YOU'VE GOT TO DO
IT.
>> Reporter: HIS OWN EMPLOYEES
FACE CRIMINAL CHARGES FROM THE
INFO WAR EDITOR WHO STREAMED THE
RIOT.
>> FEELS GOOD TO BE IN THE
CAPITOL.
>> Reporter: TO INFO HOST WARS
WHO WAS RIGHT BY JONES' SIDE.
>> 1776!
>> Reporter: AT LEAST 20 OF
THOSE ARRESTED WORKED FOR ALEX
JONES, APPEARED ON HIS SHOW OR
FOLLOWED HIS CONTENT.
THE MOTHER OF ONE RIOTER TOLD A
JUDGE HER SON BELIEVES
EVERYTHING ALEX JONES HAS TO
SAY.
ANOTHER RIOTER WHO ALLEGEDLY
TASED A POLICE OFFICER TOLD FBI
AGENTS THAT ALEX JONES INSPIRED
HIS JOURNEY.
>> HOW DID YOU START GOING TO
THESE RALLIES?
>> INFO WARS.
>> Reporter: TWO MEN LINKED TO
JONES FACED THE MOST SERIOUS
CHARGES FILED IN THE JANUARY 6th
RIOT, SEDITIOUS CONSPIRACY.
OATH KEEPER FOUNDER STUART
RHODES, A FREQUENT INFO WARS
GUEST, WHOSE PHONE CONTAINED AN
ENCRYPTED CHAT THAT INCLUDED
JONES.
RHODES PLEADED NOT GUILTY.
>> HEY, HEY.
>> Reporter: AND FORMER INFO WAR
REPORTER AND PROUD BOYS LEADER
JOE BIGGS WHO PUSHED HIS WAY
THROUGH THE POLICE LINES INTO
THE CAPITOL.
HE ALSO PLEADED NOT GUILTY.
JONES HAS NOT BEEN CHARGED.
BUT CNN HAS LEARNED THE JANUARY
6th SELECT COMMITTEE
INVESTIGATORS WANT TO KNOW ABOUT
JONES' INVOLVEMENT IN THE
FUNDING FOR TRUMP'S RALLY, THE
PLANNING FOR HIS MARCH TO THE
CAPITOL AND JONES' TIES TOWER,
EXTREMISTS NOW CHARGED WITH
CONSPIRING AGAINST THE
GOVERNMENT.
>> I SAID THIS, MY LAWYER TOLD
ME ALMOST 100 TIMES TODAY DURING
THE INTERROGATION, ON ADVICE OF
COUNSEL, I AM ASSERTING MY FIFTH
AMENDMENT RIGHT TO REMAIN
SILENT.
>> Reporter: JONES SAYS HE
REFUSED TO ANSWER THE
COMMITTEE'S QUESTIONS ABOUT
JANUARY 6th BUT TOLD HIS INFO
WARS AUDIENCE HE KNEW NOTHING
ABOUT A PLOT.
>> THEY ALREADY KNOW DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING.
I WASN'T PLANNING ANY VIOLENCE.
I WAS EVEN TALKING THINGS SHOULD
BE PEACEFUL.
>> HE SAID HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
A PEACEFUL TYPE OF FIGHT BUT
THAT'S NOT HOW IT'S TRANSLATED
TO PEOPLE WHO FOLLOW ALEX JONES.
>> ALEX!
ALEX!
ALEX.
>> >> Reporter: PAMELA, ONCE WE
STARTED DIGGING INTO THIS STORY
WE WERE STUNNED BY SOMETHING
ELSE, THE STAGGERING AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT ALEX JONES MAKES, HOW
EASY IT IS TO APPARENTLY FOOL
PEOPLE TO BUY PRODUCTS THAT HE
SELLS MOSTLY FROM FEAR, AND WHAT
IS FRIGHTENING IS HOW MANY
PEOPLE BELIEVE THESE LIES AND
NOW CONSIDER ALEX JONES A
TR